hey no
i don't think i've ever told this story
the way i'm telling it because this is
this is somebody's gonna [ __ ]
this is gonna get crazy because they're
gonna be calling me i'll tell you what
happened
so i get a phone call hey we want you to
come and do a video for us
and we can't pay you but we'll pay your
expenses they do all that i mean nice
limo room you know food all the [ __ ]
but i'm going to new york so it's taking
me three days
two to three days whatever you got to do
you're flying up and all that
and this will give you expenses or
whatever but we can't pay you
but if it works if we get about 150
000 to 180 000 views
we're going to discuss a contract with
you i said okay
i'll give it a whirl right give it a
wack yeah i'm doing my
my reality check program the one i
developed we'll get to that but
so i'm doing that i'm working with
police department i'm working with
schools i'm working with families i'm
trying to help court systems
and i'm struggling i mean i'm making a
living but struggling
and so they i said sure i'll do it i'll
discuss it
so i go up there i do this [ __ ] flip
and now this is why i was talking about
the world trade what does it have you do
well here's a remember the freedom tower
yeah freedom tower the whole
24th floor of the freedom tower is
con-ness travel con nest travel owns
vanity fair con nest travel is the
biggest one of the biggest
magazine companies in the country okay
in the world and they own
all these [ __ ] magazines you know uh
you'll see the the high-end boat onesies
all these [ __ ]
vanity fair all these shits so contest
travel owns
i'm telling the whole 24th floor of the
new freedom tower is all
studios man is it [ __ ] set up man
it is [ __ ] awesome i mean really i
said wow look at this [ __ ]
you know you walk by one [ __ ] studio
and it's a kitchen
and all this yeah it's a whole whole 24
floor so we're in a studio
we do a whole video takes the day you
know how it is when you're doing
production you worked in that business
you know what i mean
so i come back i get home now i have
friends in the industry a good friend of
mine billy casara who
who is don yuit's son-in-law owns a very
big camera company called stable imaging
and don you had founded 60 minutes
his daughter's one of my best friends
they're great people great people wow
and to this day i go to fire island i
don't know if you know fire island ever
hear a fire out of new york oh
biggest party place in the world really
plays out oh my god
so anyway we're out there uh but today
billy calls me we talk all the time
because yeah they're gonna offer your
contract so
in now remember they wanted 150 150 180
000 views and they usually judge views
to let you know
in about two weeks they don't say how
many in a day right
right it goes by two weeks into a month
and then two months and that's how they
gauge a video like in my videos when i
know
when i get 50 000 views in a day i know
it's going to be a good video
some take never something they run the
[ __ ]
half a million i mean so this video
in two weeks two and a half weeks gets a
million views
now they wanted 150 000. and i'm
watching the views go up
i'm waiting for a [ __ ] phone call
jesus when these [ __ ] people gonna
call me my buddy billy says lady got to
call you they got the golden egg you
know
yeah they figured man they're smart i
mean they know what they're doing they
got [ __ ] larry you know
they finally because i did tv shows with
billy that's how we met
we actually did big film like uh pilots
okay
so uh and he says to me goes how are
they gonna call
never call never call huh then i get so
[ __ ] mad now people are contacting me
finding me i don't know how emailing you
yeah everything yeah i [ __ ] i had
videos i had videos from being on tv
i opened my own youtube i said [ __ ] them
didn't even know anything about youtube
didn't know what it was i started
working my balls off and i mean
researching researching researching
reason
just me i have no team nothing right i
start uploading [ __ ] videos
i start uploading videos that's how my
my editor who's got himself a hell of a
career now
and he's gonna really nice when we cash
out
he calls me he's 20 years old he's got a
hell of a resume to kid
a great guy dary my people know him
great editor
good guy too i've already flown him to
florida
and stuff like that but so darion did
work
with the toronto raptors like he won
some awards from high school
and then he really knows what he's doing
right really graphics and editing
he calls me says hey he goes uh
i see you you know have an editor i'd
love to work and i says
yeah i can't pay you i said but
if it hits you're gonna be taken care of
and we'll work something out and all
that right
sure enough obviously it hits and all
that so
without vanity fair's stupidity i
wouldn't had my youtube channel
i would just gotta deal with them and
that would have been it and i wouldn't
be
wow so uh but you're gonna like that too
and i'm the past vanity fair they got
two million subscribers
since since since 2006 right i got a
[ __ ] million almost a million one
in [ __ ] a year year and a month or
two whatever it is
but it's funny because did they ever
reach back out yeah listen what happens
when we did the filming of that video
and you can people can look it up online
now just go to vanity fair larry lawton
it's got 9 million views that video 9
million views
they write me it's got about two million
whatever at the point they write me to
go oh without even [ __ ] sending me a
bottle of scotch
not even saying [ __ ] thank you larry
we discussed that we can't work with you
but
great job nothing not a [ __ ] thank
you
they [ __ ] write me and say we want
you to sign the release for the second
video
and all right now i got my own youtube
channel right right
i write back and i don't just write back
to whoever wrote me
i get on linkedin and i find that the
ceo
the ceo the cfo
operation every [ __ ] buddy you can
think in vanity fair with a title
i cc them on email very professional
uh i received your email
not only do you not have permission to
post my video so that's no
i wanted to say how disappointed i was
in why you didn't honor your deal
and you still owed me 491 dollars
they paid that i get a check in a week
for the 491 dollars what was that for
the travelers
expenses and stuff like that i said and
i and but i said but thank you very much
for doing that because you started my
youtube career
yeah i'm sure my buddy says
people were fired they had to be fired i
mean they [ __ ] up
you know it's like it's like you know
you got something in front of you
and you see it work there's numbers are
there i mean no numbers numbers don't
lie
and now it's got 9.1 million views i
think it is some crazy number
and it's but they could have had that on
how many videos i was going to do a deal
with them
and they could have made a ton of money
i was going to accept the deal good
money but i really accept the deal what
the hell i do videos whatever
yeah but now i got this going and i love
it because the voice
gives me an opportunity to help more
people right to do
do more with a lot of people and i think
that's important
and and it's funny because we started
that conversation everybody who knows me
on my channel oh he's [ __ ] all over
the place that's larry
yeah that's you know things come in your
head that's what makes you so great
well it comes in your head you know what
i mean yeah yeah things hit you
oh [ __ ] yeah yeah just [ __ ] ask it if
i could ask
you just do it because you're going to
forget about it anyway right and then
you know what the [ __ ] was that
trust me when you get older it'll be
worth it but it so i look at it like
listen it is what it is we're going to
get to the point we're going to get
where we're going
whether it's my old career as a gangster
whether it's how i start a reality check
and that's a great story
foreign